okay so moving on to the the first thing
that uh I see as a weakness in people
they take the
Ken and I'm so about other films it
should be at your eye level if you're
training on your own and doing the
subur the biggest weakness I see and
we've all done it I've been since since
he do it but he said not to do it now
it's these trigger we call trigger
fingers so if the trigger fingers and
you'll see them in high grades as well
High grades he said that because it
stands out so
much it's obvious that that would be a
place an attacker would hit because it's
an obvious uh you they break it you may
not think
that it's important but it's it stands
out that's the problem okay so you don't
want it stand out so you just curl it a
little just curl it a
little okay and curl this
one the small finger should be half on
and half
off the end of the K I don't know why
and the two fingers should be the ones
that holding it strong
but but the weakness that I'd like to
just cover here is Trier
fingers you a lot of people they they'll
do
this rather than that you know so the
finger will be over it so the fingers
are very important to take note of so we
need to not do this it is also uh with
the Joe you'll notice people doing it
with the Joe as well
it's an unnecessary habit that we get
into so we we weakness number
one so tried to correct that weakness
number two now if you see the gap
between my
hands it's much smaller in this
case than the size of my
hand so really since you say it's one of
your hands distance
so so that's cuz I got large hands
that's the size of my
Gap when people are cutting when people
are cutting normal Cy to
parallel here to
parallel the hands pretty much stay
together I've
notice they sometimes close down a
little bit they don't close and a great
gear so when they're doing a full like
first
subur soul soul practice they come down
and and it's there when they're striking
to a partner's head as soon as they go
into partner practice they stri
partner's head because they seem to
stretch away from them this comes down
and sometimes it almost comes
together so watch out that you don't do
this and watch out for others if you're
a spectator see if they're doing it so
again this cup to the Head it closes
them if this happens it's because of two
reasons one is you're reaching you're
trying to sort of reach perhaps not with
your body but with the K and as you
reach with the Ken that
hands slides down without you knowing
it I don't know why it doesn't do it
when they cut
parallel or it doesn't happen as much
but when they're cutting to a person's
head whatever side it seems to come
close and slip
down if you find you can't stop this try
entering more with your
body okay well because rather than
throwing like a a fishing rod or a
fishing line where the hand is
sliding try to move your body so that
your body
[Music]
moves in okay so there's uh two points
that you should uh try to to work
on thank you very
much